The MIT Museum is MIT's window on the world,
and it's also the world's window on MIT.
Our job in the Museum is to make research
and innovation as available and accessible
to ordinary folks as we possibly can.
We're trying to test something that Albert
Einstein had called "spooky actions at a distance."
We're testing does the world of the very small,
the world of atoms and parts of atoms, obey
something called quantum entanglement.
We're always interested, in the Museum, in
current research at MIT.
This particular piece of research intrigued
me because it deals with some of the most
basic ideas in physics, which are in turn
some of the most basic ideas we have about
the way the universe works.
We were very, very luck to get support for
the experiment, the series of experiments,
from the U.S. National Science Foundation.
The NSF always puts a high premium on what
they call "public outreach," or "public engagement."
There are a lot questions being asked in the
United States today about "what's the point
of science?," and particularly "what's the
point of basic research?"
Research that's asking really fundamental
questions.
And this is a very good example of that, so
this is research which is really probing some
of the most basic features of the world we
live in.
Right from the beginning, my colleagues and
I started to brainstorm what we might be able
to do with this topic, within our museum.
The project we've conceived is very, if you
like, multimedia.
We have some exhibition components, we've
got some displays being built in the Museum,
we also have programs, we have some seminars
and some educational programs.
But alongside that, maybe some drama might
also help here.
We have a unique, and created just for this
project, one-act play that was developed by
the Central Square Theatre as part of the
Catalyst Collaborative at MIT.
I had never even heard of quantum entanglement
before, and it was just mind-boggling.
And, of course, the idea ... now you're going
to write a 20-minute play about this thing
that's really hard to visualize, we can't
really draw a picture of it ... that was a
really big challenge, and I like challenges.
I like challenges a lot.
The play will run in the Museum on many occasions,
so Museum visitors can come and experience it.
And before or after, of course, explore the
exhibit with the student-made components.
So this exhibition is a pretty concise installation
of the concept, where we have MIT students
who are physicists and mathematicians coming
in to actually think about the subject matter
and how to represent it visually.
Here in the Museum, we love to work with MIT
students--undergraduates and grad students.
We think that they get a lot out of learning
how to communicate about science, and we get
a lot from their energy, their enthusiasm,
and their smarts, really.
Our project is called Spooky Action, and it
is a way for people to experience quantum
entanglement, specifically a process whereby
two particles can actually influence each other's
behavior just by being physically separated.
And so we tried to visualize that effect by
using a strobe light to highlight certain
positions of the rotating ball.
And so, the ball's rotating at a constant
rate, it's always continuously moving, but
the strobe effect makes it look like it's
frozen in space.
There are multiple ways that museum visitors
can explore this concept: through the performance,
through the exhibit, and through the very
many public programs that we're running in
conjunction with the entire topic itself.
I think we enjoy the challenge of coming up
with new ways of connecting with audiences.
We try to create an engaging setting, maybe
a non-traditional setting, where folks might feel welcome.
If we can excite even a couple of adults or
children to want to take that deeper dive,
that really was the overarching goal here,
that gave us the freedom to try these other
modalities and mediums in how we communicated
this topic.
The MIT Museum wants to be an experimenter.
It wants to find new ways of taking science
to new audiences.
And I think this is going to take a step further
forward ... To really say, lets wrestle with these
hard concepts and not shy away from them.
What can we do to try to help people get their
hands around this kind of complicated thing?
I think you wrap all of those together, you
have a really amazing experience for an audience.
I think they'll say, wow, this is wondrous.
And if we can inspire a sense of wonder, I
think that's really exciting.